hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy where we talk to influential
people in the field of education i am
excited today to talk with dr dan
willingham
before we get started with that i want
to remind all of you that khan academy
is a non-profit that relies on donations
from folks like yourself to help
help us help keep more people learning
and you can find the the space to donate
there on on our site
also during the pandemic we have
required some extra support to help keep
us going and make sure that all learners
have those opportunities that they have
needed for digital learning in this in
this time and we want to particularly
thank bank of america
at t
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors for their support
all
thankful for all of that oh that help
and finally we want to
remind you that there's an audio version
of our ed talks that's available
homeroom with sal the podcast available
wherever you get your podcasts so
take a look at that you can find
previous episodes and review favorites
while you're while you're looking for
those
so today
as i said i'm excited to talk to dr dan
willingham
when people ask me hey where can i read
more about
learning science and how people learn
his book why don't students like school
it's one of the first place i send
places i send people to and the second
edition of that book is out this week so
go find that at your favorite bookseller
and it in addition to all the good
previous content it also covers
educational technology which is of
course a a place uh that is near dear to
my heart but uh dan welcome and thanks
for joining us
hi kristin i'm so glad to be here thanks
for having me
absolutely
so i'm gonna as usual in these talks
start off with some questions that i
have from uh
reading your works and then we'll go to
audience questions so those of you who
are listening feel free to add things
and questions into the chat and i will
pick those up as well
but i'm interested in starting and
thinking about
curiosity which is something that you
talk about upfront in in one of your
first chapters and thinking about
it's there's things that it seems like
we're curious about and there's some
natural curiosity when you think about
young kids asking questions and where
that is
but then sometimes it seems to kind of
fade away and
there's like we kind of lose some of
that
so how should we think about curiosity
and helping us learn
so yeah curiosity is one of the things
that i just find so fascinating because
i noticed this in myself before i was a
cognitive psychologist or study things
like uh study any of these things
formally
uh
we think of curiosity as being driven by
content and so you think like i'm a
cognitive psychologist so i am curious
about cognitive psychology and the truth
is like that's sort of true but not
remotely true
as a general rule i have been to many
many conferences and attended cognitive
psychology talks and found myself
extraordinarily bored and i'm sure
everybody listening to this talk now has
had the same experience you you go into
something you start reading a book or
watch a youtube video because you're
like oh i love this stuff this is going
to be great and then it's horrible and
then the opposite can equally uh
happen equally often where somebody you
know sort of forces you to watch
a youtube video about how they make
dumbbells and you're like that can't be
interesting and then oh my god it's
totally fascinating
so i think the through line for
curiosity you mentioned kids and how
kids seem to be curious about everything
and then like we
adults not so much we're much more
selective the kind of through line for
that i think is curiosity is all about
learning about your environment
and so we are continually sizing up our
environment and figuring out is this um
is there an opportunity for learning
here and learning um
uh the the the way you make that
calculation is it
the the unknown needs to be at sort of
just the right level um so if
you offer me some information and it's a
topic like if you said to me hey would
you like to know who the first president
of the u.s is i'm like that doesn't make
me very curious because i already have
that information right likewise if you
said would you like to know who the
first president of
you know chad was i'm like sort of but
like i really don't know anything about
chad and so that's not gonna help me
very much so it's when there's
information that's going to add to what
we already know that seems to be a
really critical
trigger for curiosity and that helps us
understand why small children are
curious about everything they don't know
anything so there's they can they're
they are um
uh well positioned to be sponges and be
curious about everything because the
world is offering all this information
and they don't know anything about the
world
that's great so as you said you're a
cognitive psychologist and a professor
of psychology what was your path to
getting to that place in your career how
did you come to be a cognitive
psychologist
i came to vehicle it was it was very
much a matter of curiosity um
both my parents were actually
psychologists neither one of them a
cognitive psychologist but they both um
had degrees in experimental psychology
my dad went off and became a
psychometrician my mother later became a
counselor
and my uncle was also an experimental
psychologist so like i was really
determined not to do anything to in
psychology at all
but then in college i thought gosh i
guess i i need to take like intro to
psychology or something so that i can
keep up at thanksgiving dinner
um so i did and i found myself
absolutely fascinated and then i started
taking you know a broad array of courses
uh and cognitive psychology just really
uh just really i
want to say caught my fancy which isn't
is a weird turn of phrase but that
pretty well describes it um i just
couldn't get enough of it and so decided
to go to graduate school and just keep
doing what i loved
that's great and i love the i don't want
anything to do with what my parents did
but oh it's actually kind of interesting
too
yeah yeah absolutely
um so thinking generally across your
education experience were there any
particular teachers who influenced you
or that you found really uh helped you
on your path
i mean gosh i had so many um amazing
teachers i mentioned that i
was really captivated by cognitive
psychology in college um and ruth day
was the professor who taught that course
and i took a psychology of language
course afterwards with her i did a
senior thesis with her so she was
certainly extremely influential in
developing my love of psychology i also
have to single out
my fifth grade teacher richard lee were
who was just a really really inspiring
teacher and
really made me come to school
excited to learn every day and also
really managed to help me see that
school was something i was doing for
myself i think up until that point i
kind of went to school just because like
your kid and that's what you do and like
to the extent that i had any skin in the
game so to speak it was like i was doing
this to make my parents happy like if i
didn't go my parents would be mad at me
and mr leewar actually really made me
see
that learning was something that was fun
and something that i appreciated and
something i benefited from
so you know i couldn't tell you exactly
what content i learned in fifth grade
from him but i
will never forget that sort of attitude
towards school and that attitude towards
learning
that's great
actually when people ask me about
teachers myself my fifth grade teacher
was also very influential in what we did
so i wonder too if there's something
about that age that
gets people
um so you we were talking about how
that that kind of um
inspiration but also building on what
you learned and what you know and where
those are
so there's a lot of we talk about in
motivation finding uh meaning for
learning and one of the things that can
help motivate students is finding
meaning in what they're doing and i know
lots of teachers get the question of
when am i going to use this why do i
need this
how should we help build meaning and
what do we do when it seems like the
things that we need to learn don't have
a lot of meaning in them
yeah i mean i
i comment on this a little bit in
why don't students like school and in a
way it's a it's a stance that concerns
me a little bit
i don't feel like
will students find this meaningful
now is a very good litmus test to uh to
which we should hold content and the
reason for that is i think there's a lot
of things that students
will enjoy knowing will find beautiful
will uh maybe even find important that
they don't feel fine meaningful in their
life as as they would describe it in
other words if you try and tempt them
with look this is something that
is important for you to know is and
you're going to find it interesting and
important in your daily life i think
first of all i think a lot of times
that's going to be feel really strained
for us
because a lot of what we as adults kind
of in in our much more mature judgment
think this is important for a fifth
grader to learn about
it's not immediately obvious to the
fifth grader that yes that's going to be
meaningful to me but in contrast we can
we were talking about curiosity you can
make people curious about things to say
like look here's this puzzle here's this
odd uh here's this fact in mathematics
like how why does it work that way or
here's this fact in science why what is
that all about um i think that's a more
when we're talking about motivation yes
things seeming personally meaningful
personally relevant to me that can be
powerful um but i think that will
greatly narrow the scope of what it is
we want students to know about also
worry a little bit
candidly that it it
sends an implicit message that the
students are kind of in the driver's
seat in other words if i'm continually
trying to show students this is
meaningful to you this is meaningful
that also sort of implies the contra the
um the counterpoint that well if i don't
think it's meaningful then that maybe
means i shouldn't be learning it um and
i i don't think that uh fifth graders
should have that uh control i think that
teachers are the ones who should be
deciding this is what's important for
you to learn right now and it's
incumbent on me to make you intrigued
about it
interesting so i just as you were
talking had this thought as you said
that about them not deciding it also
triggered in me some of the
conversations around
um
diversity and inclusion and that just
because it's not relevant to
me let's say the you know
upper middle class
white fifth grader in the suburban
school
doesn't mean that it's not something
that i should know to be able to
understand the experiences of other
people too
um and where that is so i wonder if
there's a link there
i i agree and i mean i i think that's
especially
um point not poignant but it's
especially important to consider uh in
the realm of human experience to so so
to sort of say like what do i have to
learn about this story that's about
somebody who's totally unlike me like no
that's kind of the point is first of all
you're you uh it's interesting and
important to learn about the
perspectives of people from other
cultures people who are not like you and
second of all you're going to see some
similarities that maybe you didn't
expect that there is universality in the
human experience and how are you going
to know that um unless you read about
some people who are different than you
are
yeah absolutely
fascinating um i do want to get a little
bit to talking about um
in the the
the realm of technology so
in covid and we've you know even more
started relying on digital learning
environments and
one of the things that we hear sometimes
is are all of these phones and screens
changing how people learn are they
getting different dopamine hits or our
attention spans changing um what are
your thoughts on that
well there's a lot of pieces you know
just in your question right there was
really like three different questions in
there
um about whether you know our screen's
changing our brains do we learn let's
let's take those two questions our
screens changing our brains and then do
we learn differently from screens
um the idea that screens are changing
our brains uh i've argued that's very
improbable and the reason i argue that
the the main way that people have
suspected that screens are changing our
brains is that they are reducing
attention span
or and or reducing uh working memory
span uh first of all we have data that
that's not happening so there's certain
tests of working memory that have been
administered for close to 100 years and
so we actually have data from limited
populations not you know worldwide or
anything uh but we certainly have amer
american samples and we know that
working memory span just hasn't changed
uh with the digital revolution so we
actually date on that and then also from
a theoretical perspective um you just
wouldn't expect the brain is plastic
this is frequently what you hear the
brain is plastic and so how could it not
change in response to the all this
experience with screens
and what i would say to that is the
brain is plastic but it can't be that
plastic so take working memory in
particular there's so many cognitive
processes that depend on working memory
reading problem solving
mathematics all the things we care about
in school basically really depend on
working memory capacity so if working
memory capacity were really plastic and
really changed with the environment and
it shrunk the
impact would cascade throughout the
cognitive system and basically uh if
everybody would be really stupid if
working memory capacity shrunk
significantly
now in terms of whether or not we learn
differently from screens it's pretty
clear that we do
and
just think about zoom fatigue that's
enough to start you with i mean this is
what everybody has found during the
pandemic
the signal that you're getting from a
screen is not as rich as the signal that
you get from a live human being and so
one of the ways you're dealing with that
is you're expending more cognitive
effort trying to make up for that signal
the you know you don't for one thing you
frequently don't have gestures you can
occasionally see i sort of
self-consciously i'm trying to keep my
hands up here so you can getting a
little bit more signal from that
frequently though you know you're you're
looking at a talking head you're not
getting any gestures
um the the two-dimensionality obviously
makes a difference um the you get a lag
there's all these problems with uh with
screens and so what the viewer is doing
is they're expending more cognitive
energy trying to extract everything they
can from that signal
um so learning from screens and they're
when little kids are not very good at
those little kids really get uh have
problems with screens and if you google
the term video deficit you can find some
of this some of this research literature
so certainly you can learn from screens
but it's not the same experience
and we've made enormous strides in the
last 10 or 15 years and figuring out how
to do this effectively
um but they're still issues that we that
we're trying to overcome
yeah absolutely so do you have
recommendations about
you know screen time and the amounts of
how much should parents or teachers be
thinking about the amount of time
students are spending on screens i mean
like most people i'm uh you know i'm
very quick to say well it depends on
what they're doing on their screens
but the truth is like if your child is
unsupervised uh when they're
you know uh have a laptop or have an
ipad or something
you kind of know what they're doing it's
not they're not looking at shakespeare
concordances you know and there there
are data on this that they're they're
mostly consuming video content they're
texting their friends i mean the way i
put it in um when students like school
is they're basically doing the stuff
that kids have always liked to do and
they're just doing it with technology
now when i was left to my own devices
when i was nine years old when i was 15
years old i was mostly not doing the
most enriching things
and so it's really less about like
you know what what do you want your kids
to be doing is it really the screen per
se or is it that gosh i wish they were
reading
you know reading more books or i wish
they were reading more nonfiction or i
wish they were working on their social
skills more whatever it is
whatever it is you want them to do
they can probably do it on a screen they
can probably do it off a screen
so you need to figure out how you're
going to encourage your child to engage
in more of the activities they want i
think the thing that really bugs people
about screen time is screen time is
mostly unsupervised and yeah most of
what kids do when they're unsupervised
on screens is you know in the long run
not super enriching it's kind of fun for
them but not very enriching
i have to say like there's plenty of
rules in my house and like
this is especially accurate with the
pandemic i mean like like most parents
like we had lots of rules in my house
and then the pandemic struck and i all
my wife and i are like just play among
us all you want like whatever whatever
it is like you know this is just a
nightmare for everybody like you know i
can't blame you just do whatever you
want to do
do whatever
absolutely absolutely um so we talked
about screens there's actually a comment
from youtube uh venkat parkanen
who says that more audio learning should
be implemented i never used audio
learning in my high school but it's so
much powerful now and so i wonder if do
you
have thoughts about how learning is
impacted by different communication
methods or channels
yeah i mean that's been um pretty
carefully researched when it comes to
reading so the comparison being reading
text versus listening to an audio book
um i don't know that there's been a lot
of research on you know audio learning
more broadly
um there's a whole lot of over so i'll
comment on um
reading from print versus an audio book
there's a whole lot of overlap in the
mental machinery that comprehends
printed text versus listening to the
same text someone read the same text
this is assuming that you are a very
smooth fluent decoder when you're
reading print so in other words going
from print on the page to words in the
mind is no problem for you you're quite
you're quite facile with that if you are
there's a whole lot of overlap between
the two processes is basic because the
processes that you use to
comprehend written text is basically the
same process you use for oral language
there's some differences
um around the margins which are not
trivial so one that's pretty obvious is
when you're listening to a book
someone's reading it to you and so you
get uh what what uh scientists call
prosodic information prosody is the sort
of music of
um
of speech and it's what tells you the
difference between uh what a great party
and what a great party right so sarcasm
is all a matter of prosity uh and so in
that sense listening to a text is a
little bit easier because the whoever's
doing the reading is giving you that
prosodic information
on the other hand when you're reading
print it's very easy to move backwards
in a text
you control the pace you can read as
quickly as slowly as you want and it's
real easy to go backwards so you uh and
if you look at eye movements while
people are reading something like 10 15
percent of eye movements are actually
regressions where you're going back you
had a little bit of trouble unraveling
the syntax of a sentence maybe so you go
back to pick up a few words
in principle you can go back when you're
listening to an audio book but in
practice it's kind of awkward and most
people don't really do it and of course
um you're not in terrific control of the
pace
um so that makes audiobooks slightly
more difficult so again lots and lots of
overlap
but the
some differences at the margins
got it thank you we've got a few more
questions coming in um on facebook
so one of the things we keep hearing and
shelly costa thompson asks a question
related to that now is
how do you keep teens motivated um
especially this year but over time just
it seems to be an ongoing question of
how we keep them interested in wanting
to learn
how we yeah how we keep students
interested in school
yeah particularly teams but yes
particularly teens yeah and i don't know
whether the question is really like from
a parental perspective versus from a
teacher's perspective because i think
the it is she has a 14 year old
okay so it's from a parental perspective
yeah no i mean it gets difficult because
lots of other things crowd around uh in
on their time and
teens in particular
become extraordinarily interested in
their social lives
um
bj casey is a psychologist at yale
university has a very good take on this
i think she points out that this is
practice for them this is preparation
for becoming independent of their
parents so they're becoming extremely
attuned to their peers because they're
now
learning how to navigate this world
where other people
are going to be important important as
they as they move out of their home
uh so with that kind of competition you
know trig just does not seem to hold a
whole lot of appeal
um i think one of the one of the things
that um
is important to do and it's certainly
not going to be a full-blown solution um
is to emphasize that this is a family
value and i hope that this is something
that has been a family value all along
and to sort of acknowledge and validate
like i get it that there are other
things you're interested i also get it
mr willingham your history teacher is
pretty boring like that's legit i'm not
i'm not saying that he's not
at the same time like some things have
not changed and one of the things that
hasn't changed is in this family we take
school seriously you know we show up on
time we uh we are
talk
politely to our teachers all the sorts
of things that you've been doing all
along are important and want to continue
to be important and one of the things
that continues to be important is trying
your best in all of your classes and
making sure that you make time for that
so i in general i'm i'm very much a fan
of trying to start with uh positivity
and trying to start with
uh sort of appealing to the best in sort
of a teen sense of self like sort of
saying like look this is who you are
right this is the best version of you
that you want to be you want to be the
kind or you are the kind of person who
treats school this way as opposed to the
punitive approach like well look you
know if you're not going to do your work
then i'm going to take your ipad away
because that's obviously not appealing
to the best in the student
and i also find that it it ends up being
a little bit of a game of cat and mouse
it's sort of like well you know you're
not doing what i want you to do
therefore i'm going to do this to you
and that to me sort of sets up a bargain
in the child's mind like okay so if i
can still get away with not doing what
you want me to do and retain my ipad
then i'm kind of winning
whereas if i'm if i'm appealing to their
sense of self then they themselves kind
of know
whether or not they're living up to that
so if i if i can do it that's going to
be my starting place
got it thank you
and i know that's a whole uh how to
motivate teens could be a whole new
series of series of books
[Laughter]
i feel your pain for sure
definitely definitely um so
you've been thinking about motivation
you know we talked earlier about
curiosity
i wonder if there's something to with um
the you know link thinking about
motivation curiosity i know you've
talked recently about creativity too
and if there's you know appealing to
students creativity or opportunities
there to
encourage students and to keep being
interested in learning
i i think absolutely i mean and this is
something that i think most parents want
to do this and i think most parents
are are doing it as as much as they can
but encouraging creative outlets that
are not necessarily part of school i
think is a wonderful opportunity to keep
kids engaged with learning i mean
especially kids who are struggling a lot
in a lot of their school subjects that
feeling that um
because what what you're really worried
about and sort of trying to guard
against is a sense of
self that doesn't include
learning at all you know it's sort of
like well school is not a place where i
succeed school is not a place where i
feel good about myself
um and so that sort of extends to any
type of learning that might happen
period right because schools where you
learn in contrast to if if a student can
feel like yeah the stuff i do at school
like i really struggle with that that's
really hard for me and i don't i'm not
sure i see that in my future long term
but then there's this other content that
i feel really passionate about i i know
i'm good at that
and that entails learning and i'm good
at that type of learning
that seems like a really desirable way
to go and it does obviously it doesn't
just apply to students who are
struggling in school this is you know
having that passion especially feeling
like they can go deep on something one
of the things that i know is so
frustrating for students is
everything is you know sort of a million
miles wide and two inches deep and so
getting to the point where they feel
like they've real they're really getting
mastery and like they know more about
this than most adults do that's like you
know that's really exciting for them and
you know every kid deserves to feel that
way
absolutely that seems like a good note
the half hour's flown by
so we will wrap it up there thank you so
much for your time today again folks dr
dan willingham check out the second
edition of his book that's out now
and the uh will remind all of you as
well that tomorrow at the same time we
have ben gomes from we'll be talking
about new learning initiatives at google
so you can join us then thanks again to
dr dan willingham for joining us all of
you have a good day and we will see you
next time
you